a examiner au cas par cas leur situation
je considère
Emmanuel Bert bonsoir vous êtes beaucoup
investi dans ce ce mouvement des
sint-papiers de Saint-Bernard en
partageant des jours et des nuits avec
eux et en vivant cette cette opération
d'évacuation jusqu'à la fin ce matin ce
soir vous êtes vous êtes déçu je vous
voyez choqué en voyant ces images
c'estàd d'abord je voudrais dire que je
ne suis pas là en tant que comédienne
mais en tant que femme mère de deux
enfants et j'ai l'impression j'ai le
sentiment que si je ne témoigne pas de
ce que j'ai vu ce
matin je ne pourrais plus ni vivre ni
dormir en paix donc voilà je suis là
pour ça ce que nous avons montré ce que
vous avez montré à la télé
euh je dirais que c'est peut-être bien
loin de la de la
souffrance de tous les enfants avec qui
je suis restée jusqu'au bout avec qui
nous sommes restés jusqu'au bout je
voudrais aussi ajouter que sur certaines
images on ne voit pas qu'il y a eu
plusieurs viols notamment une église
dont les portes ont été
euh détru à coup de hache des vitres
cassées des enfants moi pour ma part
j'avais un petit enfant parce que les
enfants s'accrocha à nous en essayant de
comprendre dans une sorte de de terreur
des larmes de de criis un petit enfant
sur mes genoux qui a fait pipi tellement
il avait peur qui retrouva ni son père
ni sa mère tout ça pour vous dire
que j'ai j'ai beaucoup de mal à parler
parce que c'est encore très récent et de
revoir toutes ces images ce soir c'est
très difficile pour moi vous avez trouvé
cette opération très violente plus par
je dirais moralement moralement
extrêmement violente on a pour
moi violer la dignité de ces gens ces
gens ont été traqués errés d'endroit
d'église en
gymnase pendant des mois et des mois je
ne comprends pas pourquoi on a laissé
pour pourir la situation si il fallait
étudier au cas au cas par cas pourquoi
ne l'a-t-on pas fait avant pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a laissé ses enfants ces
femmes ces hommes ces célibataires ces
gréistes de la fin aller aussi
loin je suis indigné révolté mais j'ai
surtout mal j'ai surtout mal pas pour
moi qui a été arrêté pendant 2 heures au
commissariat et qui a été relâché
extrêmement vite mais je pense à eux ce
soir voilà donc de les revoir là tous
dans la mesure où les les sans papiers
n'avaient pas vouloir l'air de vouloir
accepter négociation cas par écoutz moi
hier soir j'étais dans l'église on a
pendant 5 mois ces gens ont demandé à
être entendus on a refusé absolument
tout dialogue le gouvernement je tiens à
préciser que je ne suis d'aucun parti
politique d'accord voilà qu'est-ce qui
vous a poussé à mettre votre image votre
personnalité je j'ai débarqué un jour
j'ai débarqué il y a quelques temps tout
simplement par solidarité humaine avec
des couches du lait je suis moi-même
mère de deux enfants j'ai eu
l'impression qu'il était important d'y
aller et d'aider je savais que les
familles commençaient à manquer de
produits de base de choses essentielles
et donc j'ai débarqué là comme ça et
puis je suis restée parce que j'ai eu un
sentiment d'justice on a répété pendant
des mois qui s'agissait de clandestin
j'ai donc appris en venant et en parlant
avec tous les gens qui étaient autour de
moi les délégués africains qu'il il
s'agissait de de gens mis en en
clandestinité par les lois parce quoi
c'est-à-dire que je n'ai rencontré que
des gens qui ont travaillé en France qui
ont une famille ou qui sont célibataires
mais les célibataires c'est pas parce
qu'on s'est pas reproduit qu'on a pas le
droit qu'on a pas le même droit que les
autres euh je n'ai rencontré que des
gens qui ont essayé de former une
famille de former de se de de de vivre
ici où la vie est dure mais possible
dans leur pays on souffre moi je viens
de Mauritanie les gens crèvent là-bas au
Mali les gens crèvent aussi je comment
vous dire je
j'ai vous espériez une autre attitude
une autre issue à ce une autre attitude
du gouvernement une autre issue dans
monur ce que j'ai vu ce matin je ne
l'oublierai jamais mais c'est pas très
grave ce que les enfants ont vu ce matin
ils noublieront non plus et c'est très
grave ils n'oublieront pas non plus
c'est très grave merci en tout cas
d'avoir bien voulu nous apporter votre
témoignage ce soir l'intervention des
forces de l'ordre à l'église
Saint-Bernard est unimement condamné à
gauche